you recently warned that specula you
being you Bob Shiller recently when
speculative bubbles were emerging in the
housing sector in different parts of the
world especially in Brazil right and
asks you know if there are particular
actions that Brazilian policymakers
should take at this point and more
broadly what would be the implications
for other emerging markets if if they
don't do anything there isn't a science
to controlling bubbles it's a little bit
like can you know there's a mental
illness called manic depressive
psychosis and we now know that lithium
works as a drug but we don't have it
works in perfectly in that case we don't
have drugs like that for speculative
bubbles and we're reliant on therapy of
a more basic sort there's many things
that governments have been doing to
limit bubbles they can put limits on
loan on the amount of loans that are
given out by banks they can put
restrictions against buying a second
home and you know our own dodd-frank act
in 2010 created some measures that will
help prevent bubbles but again you never
know when these things are adequate
because the the bubble phenomenon is
essentially psychological and you know
it's like trying to control a crowd if
you have an angry mob outside your door
what scientific method can I use to
control them well there really isn't any
you can try to talk to them and maybe it
will work maybe it won't